une à une telle claque aux attentes
dans la douleur les victimes de l'aréna
ce ont témoigné de leur vie brisée
ici on délire durant sept jours dans un
tribunal du michigan
elles ont dénoncé avec courage ce
monstre qui devait les soigner 160
gymnastes dont cinq médaillés d'or qui
pour la plupart étaient mineurs au
moment des viols ce médecin dit cette
jeune femme était notre abuseurs un
abuseurs d'enfants
la plupart des agressions ont eu lieu à
l'université d'état du michigan où
travaillait n'assure il était le médecin
de l'équipe olympique américaine de
gymnastique was in fact saxo
je croyais affirme cette victime qu'il
s'agissait d'une procédure médicale mais
c'était en fait une agression sexuelle
le violeur utiliser ses doigts pour
pénétrer ses filles est aussi jeune que
six en leur laissant croire à un
traitement qui permet au groupe faw
riccio de nolan 2 est la première à
l'avoir dénoncé des familles entières
ont été dévastées par les sévices subis
par leur fille
emilie ces survivantes ont sévèrement
blâmé l'université et l'association
américaine de gymnastique qui se sont
réveillés trop tard
aucune excuse de l'accusé ne pourra
guérir
autant de femmes blessées nous sommes
les fans la juge rosemary aquilina s'est
dit honoré de prononcer sa sentence elle
le condamne à 175 ans de prison
je viens dit la juge de signer votre
arrêt de mort la rina se retourne donc
dans sa cellule où il purgeait déjà une
peine de 60 ans de prison pour
possession de pornographie juvénile
ici christian latreille radio-canada
washington